and welcome to Hannity we begin tonight
with the Fox News Alert and breaking
just now this is huge the FISA Court
they just issued an extremely rare
rebuke public order rebuking commis FBI
for misleading the court I told you if
you have premeditated fraud on the court
it's never a good idea I wouldn't even
lie to Judge Judy now this FISA judge is
now demanding that the FBI come up with
a proposal to prevent another massive
abuse of power this is just the latest
fallout from the IG s damning FISA abuse
report we're gonna have all the details
that the mob and the media will probably
ignore because they've missed the whole
story now but first we do turn to the
Washington swamp Democrats they have now
decided that a toxic political stunt is
obviously more important than the rule
of law our constitutional republic basic
fairness due process our great
constitution and the will of we the
American people because breaking moments
ago the president well he's fighting
back and what is a powerful scathing
beat down the president accused Speaker
Pelosi of declaring open war on American
democracy with a partisan impeachment
crusade that represents an unprecedented
and unconstitutional abuse of power by
Democratic lawmakers with more due
process afforded to those accused in the
Salem witch trials a president Trump
went on to utterly destroy the Pelosi
and the Democrats and the shift' show
and the nutty Nadler ship show and their
idiotic articles of impeachment writing
quote your first claim abuse of power it
is a complete disingenuous meritless
baseless invention of your imagination
and the president continued quote you
are trying to impeach me by falsely
accusing me of doing what Joe Biden has
admitted he actually did and that's not
all the president also shredding Pelosi
second claim the so-called obstruction
of Congress calling it preposterous and
dangerous what do we say we have three
branches of government when the
executive branch legislative branch have
a conflict yes the executive branch in
this case has
right to seek remedy in that other
branch of government known as the
judiciary and by the way confirm with
them taking up the case last week three
for three
Jay Sekulow and the president's
attorneys now throughout history
presidents and both parties have all
asserted executive privilege the courts
decide they are the arbiter when there
are these conflicts with other branches
and by the way they'll decide if this
privilege is valid but the courts were
never given a chance why because the
Democrats are in this breathless rush to
impeach impeach and peach and as the
president's letter rightly points out
constitutional scholar Jonathan Turley
made one thing very clear during his
testimony if Democrats impeach a sitting
president of the United States for going
to the courts to seek resolution when
there is a conflict between the other
branches that would be an abuse of power
that would be Congress's abuse of power
so this circus the shifts show on
Capitol Hill full of corrupt political
stunt after stunt this will forever
stain not only the Democratic Party but
this hurts we the people remember they
don't like who we chose in 2016 who you
chose in 2016 and the speaker name only
Nancy Pelosi
well it's president Trump concluded
quote history will judge you harshly as
you proceed with this impeachment
charade your legacy will be that of
turning the house of representatives
from a revered legislative body into a
star chamber of partisan persecution and
tonight that is exactly what is
unfolding in this country driven by
irrational rage and psychotic hatred
this radical extreme new socialist
Democratic Party Nancy Pelosi is now set
to ram this impeachment through on a
party-line vote as she said she'd been
trying for only two and a half years
congresswoman Maxine Waters her dreams
of impeaching 45 about to come true for
nothing though the squad I assume
they're jumping for joy corrupt the
compromise the congenital liar Adam
Schiff I guess he'll Pat himself on the
back the celebration however that will
be short-lived because the Democrats
they're hyper partisan blood
against President Trump this will have
repercussions and dire political
consequences in the end but not for the
president he will not be convicted in
the Senate that's where Republicans hold
a majority and that's where you actually
will need real fact witnesses not
hearsay witnesses not opinion people and
get this we see the beginnings of this
demise happening and unfolding right
before our eyes look at the president's
poll numbers brand-new USA Today poll
shows the president easily defeating
every one of his potential 2020 rivals
another poll fake News CNN of all places
shows a significant drop in impeachment
and support for impeachment and
according to that survey impeachment is
even losing support among registered
Democrats so make no mistake as
congressman Doug Collins pointed out
today there will be a reckoning and the
good news is in 322 days you we the
American people we Trump supporting
smelly Walmart shoppers those of us that
believe in God our Constitution or
Bibles religion irredeemable deplorable
you get the last word and 322 days take
a look but I will remind my majority
friends and I do consider you friends
the clock in the calendar are terrible
masters and they lead to awful results
and yes there will be a day of reckoning
the calendar and the clock will continue
but what you do here and how we have
trashed the process and getting here
will live on and it will affect
everything that we've come for and so
whatever you may gain will be
short-lived because the clock in the
calendar also recognize common sense
which is not been used in this
proceeding so on November 3rd 2020 you
we the American people you decide if
this charade time money energy was
well-spent
imagine this CNN fake news can now
project Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th President of the
United States of America you can make
that happen now nearly every single
Democratic lawmaker
to walk the plank for Pelosi recent
headline left-wing New York Times quote
moderate Democrats back impeachment of
Trump as houseboater
vote nears look closely that headline
that's fake news there are no moderate
Democrats last one New Jersey
congressman Jeff Andrew he's jumping
ship and he's switching to the
Republican Party because they're not
doing a single thing for you the people
we the people what have they done in
three years except Russia Russia and
Peach impeach Muller Muller investigate
investigate haven't done a thing there's
thirty other Democrats in districts that
Donald Trump won in 2016 not
middle-of-the-road lawmakers they seemed
to be following Pelosi ship and Nadler
right off the cliff and by the way who
cares what their constituents think no
moderate politician would ever support
this partisan sham there is zero
evidence one fact witness there's
nothing wrong that was done here the
only one that did something wrong that
they totally completely and utterly
ignore is quid and Pro and quote Joe who
knew that a zero experience Sun Hunter
was being investigated so he leveraged a
billion taxpayer dollars you're not
getting the billion unless you fired the
prosecutor investigating my son who's
being paid millions for knowing nothing
for having zero experience you got six
hours son of a B now they can pretend
they're merely carrying out their solemn
duty and they're doing this with a very
prayerful way I don't buy it
and as the president pointed out perhaps
most insulting of all of this false
display of you know acting so solemn you
apparently have so little respect for
the American people that you expected
them to believe that you are approaching
the impeachment sombrely reservedly
reluctantly no intelligent person
believes that we don't believe you
you're lying okay some point we got the
compromise corrupt congenital liar Adam
Schiff he has been busy making the
rounds oh all over late-night comedy
shows of course the perfect place to be
in such a solemn time and moment let's
go hit the comedy circuit take a look I
feel like as someone on the Intelligence
Committee and when you're this
recognizable that it
means at its core that something's gone
wrong yes it can oh yes in fact I had a
rather unusual experience on my we're
here tonight I was on the phone with one
of the major airlines trying to get back
into my account because I couldn't
remember the password uh-huh so I
finally get through the Intelligence
Committee I don't know the question is
what is your dog's name your first dogs
a man I entered the dog's name but it's
too short it won't accept it so I say
won't accept my dog's name so the voice
says try impeach and I said what and he
says try impeach and I said I thought
that's what you said I was trying to be
very professional but it couldn't help I
said I'm not going to use that as a dog
clearly for Chef this impeachment isn't
part of any solemn duty he's not acting
so prayerful as many Democrats was
apparently claiming it's all about Fame
it's all about fortune and irrational
rage and hatred of all things Trump now
he's serving his own sick twisted ego
and only is ego by the way its
constituents they've had enough look at
what they thought of the shift show as a
town hall descended into absolute chaos
you know that's Adam Schiff show right
there that's what he caused by the way
and what by the way is only the latest
example sad example about he and how he
and the Democratic colleagues they don't
care they're ripping this country apart
they care not about the office of the
presidency they care not about what the
world thinks they care not about
anything about helping what you we the
people this is about this is all they
wanted to do for three years the best
part I could say tonight on the eve of
this madness that is hurting the country
is let not your hearts be troubled
because this now will go to the US
Senate Majority Leader McConnell will be
serving Democrats a healthy dose of
reality take a look it's not a
democratic leader would apparently like
our chamber
to do House Democrats homework more than
and who wants to volunteer the Sun it's
time and energy on a fishing a tradition
to see whether his own ideas could make
chairmanships
sloppy work more persuasive than Sherman
ship himself bothered to make it the
center is met doctors judge and jury to
hear a trial not to rerun the entire
fact-finding investigation because angry
partisans rush sloppily through it so
after everything Democrats have put this
country through absolutely nothing's
going to change
President Trump remains in office the
election is three hundred and twenty two
days away and you will rightfully decide
the future of this great Democratic
Republic